hello world my name is stephen leconte
if you've spent any time on buzzfeed you
might know me as the guy who does the
advice column there
uh basically the way it works is people
dm me on instagram and twitter
people send me their wildest craziest
juiciest most interesting problems and i
try to solve as many of them as i
possibly can
right here on buzzfeed for as long as i
can remember i've been the guy that my
friends turn to whenever they need
advice
i don't really know why i'm a hot mess
in virtually every life department
but i like to think i'm a logical
practical reasonable guy
quick disclaimer before we start i'm not
a therapist
please go to therapy that would not be
me that would be an accredited person
who does things much smarter than me
that said let's do this thing so i
recently got a dm from someone
who wants to know whether they should
meet up with their old high school
teacher
dear stephen that's me i'm currently 23
years old and i'm talking to my former
high school teacher
yes in all capitals i know what it must
sound like but hear me out
he taught in my school for a year and
moved away to pursue a career in law
he's a lawyer now
and that was 10 years ago i haven't met
him since we've only started talking
recently
and we have an 11-year age difference
okay so let's just do some quick mental
math here
she's 23 years old now she had him 10
years ago
which i guess means she was 13
when she had him now she's 23 and he's
11 years older than her which means he's
34.
we connect so well because we bond over
work politics and dogs
he would text me every day but nothing
too inappropriate
he's also expressed how he wants to see
me in real life and have a conversation
in person
is this a bad idea so your question was
is this a bad idea
could we flip that and ask a different
question if your question is
is this a good idea that one i can
answer and i'm pretty sure the answer is
no the guy taught you when you were 13.
that's
pretty young you're both consenting
adults now perfectly capable of doing
whatever you want to do
but the fact remains you were 13 years
old when you met him
i can't help but think there's something
a little bit off about a man
who would take on the very important
responsibility of educating young people
in their most
formative vulnerable impressionable
years
and then that same guy has the capacity
to turn around and date one of them
i'm not saying it's illegal but i am
saying
it's a little weird right if you were 20
years out of high school
or 30 years out of high school and your
teenage
life was long forgotten maybe it
wouldn't be that big of a deal
and that's just the teacher aspect of
things i would also have concerns about
the age difference even if that man had
never been responsible for educating you
and that's gonna bring me to a segment i
call
steven speaks in sweeping
generalizations that are probably gonna
get him in trouble with commenters
there are plenty of people out there who
have age differences with their partners
and they're totally in love and happy
and have a great relationship
there's nothing wrong with that however
when a 34 year old wants to date a 23
year old
i think it's worth at least asking a few
questions an 11 year
age difference isn't unheard of it's not
obscene and the older you get
the less of a gap it becomes a 40 year
old dating a 51 year old that's really
no big deal at all
but the difference in life between a 23
year old and a 34 year old
is vast sometimes when the 34 year old
wants to date someone in their very
early 20s
it means there's something else going on
maybe they're kind of immature and they
don't want to grow up
maybe there are weird things about them
that a partner their own age would know
to look for but someone younger wouldn't
recognize maybe it means they're looking
for a partner over whom they can exert
some power or control
these things are not always true by any
means but it's worth
asking yourself those questions before
you get into a relationship with someone
11 years older than you
okay but i want to bring an expert in
here because fact is
i'm not a teacher i'm just a guy i'd be
really curious to know what someone who
actually teaches 13 year olds thinks of
this
lucky for me one of my best friends in
the world happens to be a teacher of 13
year olds so i think i might call her
are you there
hi i need your help okay what's up
the teacher like maybe asked her out on
a date it's kind of unclear
she just wants to know if she should
meet up with this old teacher first for
a date or not
from a teacher who teaches 13 year olds
perspective is this a bad idea this is 1
000 a bad idea this is shady as hell
oh no tell me why there's a lot to
unpack here he taught me for a year
and then moved on to something else fine
that's the general time that most
teachers teach their students right
you're with these kids for a year and
then they move on
what happens though is that these kids
basically in your mind are always gonna
be the age they were when you taught
them
like so for instance i taught first
grade those kids are in sixth grade now
which is horrifying but whenever i see
them like in my mind
there's still those first graders that i
taught and those like little kids right
second of all 13 year olds are
unmistakably still children like i don't
care if you're like
the most emotionally mature
self-possessed physically developed 13
year old in the world like you are still
visibly a child
so like it would have been weird then
it's definitely weird now because
the way he's viewing her in his mind's
eye is still from when she was 13 and
was still a kid does that make sense
it does make sense so let's present a
hypothetical scenario here
you have a bunch of 13 year old students
right now 10 years from now
no you haven't spoken to this student
now but 10 years from now what if
they're really really hot
no there is no hypothetical situation
you could give me where 10 years from
now like what i'm going to teach them
about to kill a mockingbird and then 10
years try to date them like that's not
going to happen
i do have one confession though i just
part of me does
feel like a fraud with this whole thing
the two of us went to the same high
school
i don't know if i've ever told you this
but once upon a time
i did find one of our old teachers on
tinder
and i did match with him
that's not weird from your end stephen
it's totally normal for students to have
crushes on their teachers it's super
weird from the teacher's perspective
because that's exactly what i said
that's exactly what i said there's this
thing with education called in loco
parentis which is latin that basically
just means that like when students are
in school you're in the place of the
parent
as the responsible adult who's like
looking out for that kid right like
that's why mandated reporting laws exist
like you're the adult in the room that's
like
looking out for the welfare of that
child so it's not like a parent-child
relationship that gets developed between
teachers and students but like
that's the general vibe is that it's
like you're just
literally supposed to be the responsible
adult in the room looking out for that
kid and definitely not thinking about
wanting to date them ever in any
hypothetical situation
so what you're saying is it's a good
thing that i never met up with that it's
a great thing you never met up with this
person i'm definitely going to touch you
after this to find out who it was
because i'm super curious thank you very
much you are
such a huge help to me with this i
really appreciate it no problem
so it's time for my final thoughts here
at the end of the day it really has to
be your
decision not mine the truth is if you've
really connected with this guy
if you're attracted to him if you think
you really like him you're probably
gonna meet up with him no matter what
the guy on buzzfeed tells you to do
i hope me and my friend have given you
some things to think about here and some
important questions to ask yourself
but at the end of the day it's got to be
your decision and now i'm going to turn
to the viewers at home
what do you guys think should she go on
the date should she head for the hills
sound off in the comments with what you
would do if you were in her situation
i'm gonna read these comments because
personally i would love to know what you
guys think
oh and if you guys have any questions
for me if you've got a problem you want
me to solve
dm me i'll do my best
ah